in in NHL season at 12 it's been remarkable
not remarkable for Kings butterbach shot SW up
there by C toal and he's Reen kempe but it's the
Islanders Top Line rushing ahead Anders Lee with
one hand able to shoot it on net and got a big
rebound off the pass of talin then back to the
front and Lee got a tip but still over 20% of the
time to score a goal so I said not terrible right
Islanders penalty has been good lately after a
rough stretches a save by soken on the try from
Arthur CAD dowy opens up pump's got Clutterbuck
to go down drags and shoots change directions
Sook and lunge for a rebound shot that never came
from Byfield Mikey Anderson or fala got through
Mayfield winds and shoots big blocker saved by
talet right to Riley that one deflected up and
over the glass as P duban skates his way up near
the line a pass gets it into the the zone that
shot blocked Away by sokin and right to Holstrom
almost 7 Minutes gone opening pury Kings and
Islanders brening Burke P Goring Thomas hicky with
you tonight game three of a six-game home stand as
the shot from Carl grundstrom SW it up bashing put
the pressure on Clutterbuck grabs the puck got out
in front of backand wrapped to the to the net and
tala made a couple of stops so now the Islanders
on the power play brought to you by a Tri-State
Volkswagen dealers a power play that's been firing
on all cylinders lately P Mar right to the net
it's barel dusts it off and everybody in front of
n the puck stays on the perimeter now they come in
front for Nelson and it's Spence who jumped around
Mayfield who jumped out on the ice as Riley
came to the bench with that broken stick and
then a chance for Deno denied campe Kee to dowy
returned it again 30 seconds left in the power
play SRO kicked that one out they were looking
for Co everything hard fiala that one blocked
by Mayfield out of the box Paul Mar Mayfield
charging ahead Mayfield will skate into the
Zone Mayfield did what he could to get a shot off
leading on by gabov here's Lee from the goal line
backs it out High Raman off shot sck to Side by
cam tal below the goal line to0 M to the top the
Alla of dowy would slipped into the corner dowy
to the front and getting sck on that with sokin a
good job of protecting the crease again for sokin
Mikey Anderson shot blocked by Mayfield they get
it again and a save from soken stepped on it and
fell down in a dangerous area of the ice Paul Mary
trying to work through the stick work of Byfield
got the shot on goal angal driving for the rebound
dowy rushes through Center kicks it off for kempe
kempe snaps one on goal and it's hung on to by
sokin physical there was borzo it's kempe across
for dowy fala set up on the half wall got it
through and they score K sneaks it short side
on soken after a long seam pass connected yeah
that was a great play and a really good shot by
K as that one time did not didn't let the stick
up over his shoulders just a quick snapshot beat
soken as he gets there but just not in time what
a great pass all the way across and just watch
this is already in the net and sokin trying to
get across he had to come from one side all the
way to the other side but falo with a beautiful
passing just a great shot that's just you know
sometimes you got to say pass him Marcel Deion
for the most assists in LA Kings franchise
history yeah that's quite an accomplishment
Marcel was a heck of a hockey player put up a lot
of points GIS pass across gabov scores vladislav
gabov just under the bar and in the Kings have
open up a two nothing lead idle you watch il's
right shoulder some space open and I think forzo
going down to block the shot maybe it just gets
lost little little turnover right there yeah I
I don't think he saw it at all because he comes
out doesn't make a move he's just establishing
position it's getting screened right there maybe
in front with Moore I wonder if they're looking at
interference at all with Mo was in pretty tight to
him jump out of the way yeah L Lambert just all of
a sudden yelled hey they were about to drop that
puck kin fala dowy guarded by clutter Buck fala
touched with kopar now they get it across kempe
tapped in front and a great stretching save
Ilia stretched as far as he possibly could to
get this well they give it all the way to km and
he's hanging on Romanov comes across got to have
a little better angle so he can't pass it through
you watch the angle see he's given he's giv it up
got to come more to is Right allow him to shoot
the puck you want to shoot the puck on the short
side go ahead out high for Riley Riley right side
Mayfield to the front barzel with lots of time and
he hit the crossbar this Corbat and barzel has
really got to get something going let's just see
if there's anything there I mean he might if he's
down an inch it he might have got lucky there was
a little bit of room there as T butt trying to
be as tall as a house and kings that all starts
with a great pass by D du over lafier denied by
sokin freed it up for kemp Bas roken reaching
for his stick he's able to grab it meanwhile
the puck comes out of the zone and here goes
egg ball Pierre Eggo in on talin it's through
him and then wrapped up in his pads and carried
off to the corner and the coach's trust right
the confidence to play you that can change your
season around here is barzel grabbing that puck
hanging on to it drops it off Riley shot a rebound
score Anders Lee it's a one goal game and Andre
Lee stops in front there's theala little turnover
right in that area look at barzel with the
quickness and then time and space little back
pass to Horvat and then out in front beautiful
play right there by Andre Lee who who stops well
that excuse me that was Mike Riley that jumped
up on the play similar to his goal the other
night turn out to be an on factor is Mayfield shot
save rebound score Anders Lee has two goals in the
third period and the Islanders have come back
to even the score and it's all about the face
off win again for for the Islanders creates
that opportunity believe it's barzel gets it
back to the point quick little pass there's the
shot okay Anders Lee go to to the net nice P his
bounc there so was Andrew Lee that actually got
it back and Mayfield does a great job to get it
through big juicy rebound and England's not
able to tie Andrew Lee up and watch him push
it back and then rush to the net great play by
Andre Lee great Face Off by Corbat as Kopitar
wins that defensive Zone draw and they hit Kee
on a break and sokin comes up with an enormous
save just got to be aware of what's going on and
behind you and Riley gets caught watching the play
and sookin comes up with a huge save just got
to know where your know where your men are and
especially a guy like Kee who's been so hot so
soken bailes out his defenseman Riley came over
and it even with two minutes to play here's Paul
maray with Pou off the post Paul maray Club side
on talit still alive out in front down a gold
but it starts with a good for check turnover
and there's pal Marian gabov takes away the pass
so no choice he's got to go for it hits the post
already in what is their 26th Game of the Year
notice the king's Shootout record 0 and2 what
surprises me a little bit kempe shot deflected
by doson chipped on by Holstrom Paso a chance
to win it [Applause] SC no history tonight on
Long Island JG Pou completes the comeback in
regulation time they win it 3-2 on the second
of the Year from JG [Music] pel nothing I can
add to that Brendon just a really good effort
Paso full speed and just goes five hole with
it help hung on to it t but guest came out hard
watch him come out hard and they're just not able
to cover up the fiveable you got to drop that
stick down I'm guessing that's what he tried do